[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain the korean romantic comedy
movie the beauty inside spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie revolves around a guy named wu
jin who suffers from a rare condition on
his 18th birthday he first learned about
his condition which makes him wake up
with a different face and body every
morning he was shocked and puzzled by
his condition at first he told his
mother moonsook about his disease she
had a hard time adjusting to it but
eventually accepted him for who he is
woo jin also came clean to his childhood
best friend sengbaek who also accepted
him with moon sook and sangbaek's
support wu jin starts to embrace his
truth and learn to live with his strange
condition every morning wujin wakes up
in a different body of varying age
gender and nationality some days he's a
man a woman old young or even a
foreigner because of his condition he
can speak a different language depending
on who he wakes up that day as although
he is always someone new on the outside
he's the same person on the inside he is
now used to seeing a different face in
the mirror every morning wujin records
himself every morning on his computer to
keep a record every day is a challenge
for him as he has to accustom himself to
the changes of being a different person
he must adjust to his body eyesight
voice etc he has a collection of all
sorts of clothes and shoes to fit any
and every type of body he also has all
types of toiletries for males and
females he owns a phoropter to test his
vision each day and a foot measuring
device to measure his feet which helps
him select the right shoe wujin and
sengbaek have a furniture company called
alx which makes unique high-end
custom-made furniture for each
individual client the former works as a
furniture designer while sangbaek
handles the manufacturing and sales this
allows woojin to work in the privacy of
his own home and keep others from
finding out about him one day jin meets
a beautiful girl named yi su who works
at a furniture store he falls for her
beauty mind and kind nature he starts
visiting the store every day to see her
unbeknownst to her he talks to her in a
different avatar each time but despite
his changing appearance yi su would
always treat him the same wujin waits
until he wakes up as a handsome guy to
finally ask the girl out on a date he
takes her to the alx factory on the
first date as she has expressed deep
admiration for alx products during
wujin's many encounters with her they
eat sushi and have a great time together
he asks her on another date the next day
he wants to meet her as the same
handsome guy so he stays up all night so
as not to wake up as someone else the
next morning this goes on for several
days and woojin gets more and more sleep
deprived with each passing day the two
start falling for each other and become
inseparable over time however one day
woojin falls asleep on the metro and
wakes up as someone else afraid of
freaking her out he cancels his date
with her and decides to never see her
again however he gives in to his urges
and continues to text her he sends her a
custom-made furniture designed just the
way she likes it the furniture also
helps yeesu impress her boss wujin also
applies as a girl to work part-time at
yi sue's workplace just so he could be
close to her he befriends her and asks
to have dinner with her after work he
takes her to the alx factory and gathers
the courage to come clean about his
identity and condition to her he shows
her the videos he recorded on his laptop
where he talks about her he tells her
about the conversations they had over
dinner about antique furniture guitars
and music however isu finds it hard to
believe and thinks it is some sick prank
being played on her she tells wujin to
never contact her again and storms out
of the warehouse wujin breaks into tears
and drowns in despair isu soon starts
messaging mujin and begins to wonder
what if he was telling her the truth the
table that he had gifted her reminds her
of him every day
one day she decides to go meet him and
drops by his home wujin opens the door
as a girl and the two have dinner woo
jin explains his condition to her and
yeesu decides to sleep with him so she
could see wu jin waking up as a
different person before sleeping wujin
tells her more about his condition and
how he copes with it he reveals that he
is 29 years old he had made peace with
his condition but ever since he met her
it has gotten ever more difficult to
live with it he tried to stay away from
her but he just couldn't resist yisu
wakes up the next day to find the same
girl she had dinner with the other day
sleeping next to her she lets woojin
sleep and goes through his clothes shoes
and videos on his laptop when wujin
wakes up he wakes up as a boy yeesu
finally believes his claim and starts to
accept him for who he is on the inside
they again start to meet every day and
wujin is elated to meet the same girl he
likes for more than a week they go to
different places and talk about silly
things she gets used to wu jin one day
waking up as a middle-aged man and some
other day as a child meanwhile wujin
feels safe around her and has not known
loneliness in a long time to find each
other in the crowd wujin holds yisu's
hand to let her know that it's him with
wujin spending most of his time with yi
su he starts slacking on the work front
sangbaek starts complaining to him about
his lack of attention to his designs
woojin assures him that he will stop
being so thirsty and will refocus his
energy on work with wu struggling at
work yisu pitches a new idea to him she
advises him to start the second alx line
with standardized sizes at moderate
prices this would give more people
access to the alx world and open new
doors for the company woojin loves this
idea which surprises sang biek because
wujin always shoots down any new ideas
he pitches
one day yee soo's furniture studio
throws a party and wujin gets an
invitation yi su's boss is excited to
meet ysu's alx boyfriend she is also
interested in meeting him because
everyone describes a different person
when talking about isu's boyfriend
unfortunately on the day of the party
wujin wakes up as an old woman he goes
back to sleep and fortunately wakes up
as a decent looking man wujin finally
arrives at the party and holds yisu's
hand to let her know that it is him isu
finally gets her co-workers off her back
about wanting to meet her boyfriend and
the pair have a great time at the party
the next day wujin takes isu to meet his
mother moonsook at her shop moonsook is
happy that her son has finally found
someone he could spend the rest of his
life with she gives them her best wishes
and hopes that they won't end up hurting
each other it is not always sunshine and
rainbows for the couple
one time wujin upsets yeesu when he
randomly holds her hand in a crowd with
a new and unknown face freaking her out
seeing her hurt he apologizes to her and
promises to never do it again seeing the
two head over heels for each other
sangbaek asks his friend why he hasn't
proposed marriage to yeesu yet wujin2
had been thinking about proposing to her
but had always been on the fence about
it with sangbaek's encouragement he
decides to propose to his yi su he works
really hard to custom design a ring for
her meanwhile people begin to gossip
about yi su after seeing her out with a
different man every day this starts to
take a toll on her mental health and she
increasingly becomes forgetful she
begins to take pills to cope with her
stress anxiety and insomnia amidst all
this woo jin broaches the topic of
marriage to yi su and as expected she
isn't so keen on marriage right now she
tells him that there are many things to
consider before getting married she says
that every time he looks in the mirror
each morning he needs time to accept
himself to test his vision and to
measure his feet similarly she needs
time to think about marrying all of
those different people she also can't
imagine how she's going to introduce him
to her parents yisu's response really
upsets woo jin he had thought that they
were on the same page but it seems they
are reading two different books the
conversation overwhelms isu and she
takes a high dosage of her pills she
falls ill and is rushed to the hospital
wujin learns that she had been taking
risperidone pills for her stress and
sleeplessness he also finds an audio
message of yisu's psychiatrist advising
her not to see wujin for some time for
the sake of her mental health wujin is
taken aback by all these revelations he
wonders if it was her fault for not
telling him or if he was too blind to
notice that isu had been silently
suffering he eventually concludes that
he was the one who was blinded by
fantasy wujin can't seem to find a way
out of this and goes to meet his mother
moonsook tells him that she had expected
this would happen one day or another she
tells him that yisu will be fine as long
as woojin and her aren't together
puzzled wujin asks her what she's
talking about she then reveals that
wujin inherited this condition from his
father munsook loved wujin's father
dearly at first but people began
gossiping they accused her of being
promiscuous she tried to ignore it but
one day wujin's father disappeared he
left her a letter apologizing to her for
making her life hell wujin is moved to
tears by the revelation and he starts
wondering if he too has to leave isu for
her betterment after yeesu is discharged
from the hospital woojin meets with her
for the last time and breaks up with her
he tells her that it is the right choice
and asks her to stop taking those pills
before disappearing from her life the
breakup devastates yeesu and she thinks
about wu jin every day ten months pass
by
yeesu can now sleep without pills but
she still dearly misses woo jin one day
yeesu's boss shows her furniture designs
from a check website and asks her to
find the designer's contact details
yeesu notices wujin's trademark style in
those designs and suspects that he is
the designer she then goes to meet
sengbaek in his office however sangbaek
acts cold towards her and refuses to
talk to her about the designs and woo
jin before leaving yeesu notices a cargo
box shipped from the czech republic in
sangbaek's office further confirming her
suspicions that wu jin is in the czech
republic
realizing that being away from wu jin
hurts her more than people's gossip
yeesu flies to the czech republic an
unknown korean man answers the door at
the website's address he denies knowing
anyone by the name of kim woo jin but
isu asks to see the man's furniture
collection for her store inside she
notices shoes of different sizes and
gender further confirming that the man
is woo jin she expresses her love for
him and tells him that she wants to
spend the rest of her life with him
finally coming clean is woo jin he tells
her that he doesn't want to make her
sick again yeesu tells him she knows
that being with him is going to be
challenging but being without him is
much worse the two break into tears
after collecting themselves they then go
out for a walk in the czech republic's
picturesque capital yi su tells him that
she doesn't care if he changes every day
and she loves the kim woo-jin inside of
him the movie ends with wujin taking out
the ring he had made earlier in the film
and finally putting it on her finger
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching